ANDREW BRAGGINS: Hey,
everybody, and welcome back
to the Mobile Ads Garage.
I'm Andrew Braggins,
and with the help
of my partner, Gary
the graphics guy,
today we're going to talk
about AdMob mediation.
We'll cover how it works, what
the pros and cons are, and then
have screencasts
of iOS and Android
of sample implementations.
All right, Gary, let's
get straight into my app
so we can talk.
When you request an ad from
AdMob like this banner,
a whole bunch of advertisers
compete in an auction
to see who's willing to pay you
the most to display their ad.
When the auction is
done, the winning ad
is sent down to the
device for display.
This competition
between advertisers
is one of the ways AdMob helps
you maximize your revenue.
Now, mediation is a way
to have competition,
not only between
different advertisers,
but between entire ad networks.
When you make a request
for a mediated ad unit,
the server returns a mediation
configuration, or stack.
It's a list of which networks
to request an ad from,
ordered by which one's
likely to make you
the most money at that moment.
The SDK looks at
that list and starts
trying networks one at a
time, and the first one
to return an ad wins.
This is where AdMob
adapters come in.
The mobile ad's SDK
uses them to rap
other networks' SDKs so they
all have a common interface.
The beauty of it
is that all of this
happens automatically
under the hood.
As long as you make sure the
other SDKs and their adaptors
are built into your
app, there's usually
no other mobile work required.
So the plus side
is that you have
more networks of
advertisers competing
for your impressions, which can
mean better fill rates and more
revenue.
The downside, though, is that it
can take longer to load an ad,
and because you need
those other networks' SDKs
and adapters built
in, your app size
is bigger than it would
be with just AdMob.
Also, because you're now
dealing with multiple networks,
you have to register with
them, create ad units
in their network, and so on.
How those pros and cons
weigh out is up to you.
A lot of smaller publishers
prefer the simplicity
of using AdMob alone, while,
for others, the chance
to increase revenue makes
the extra work worthwhile.
All right, time to
get our hands dirty.
Let's take a look
at how you can use
the AdMob console
to configure an ad
unit to use multiple networks.
It's the first step toward
getting that mediation money.
Is that Peruvian money?
Why did you go to Peru?
All right, then.
OK, so if you've created
an ad unit before,
you're probably familiar
with this screen.
This is the page
that lists all the ad
units associated with an app,
in this case, my test app.
I want to draw your attention
to the mediation column
here, though.
You can see I only have one ad
source competing for this unit,
and I'd like to add another one.
So I'll click this
link and I get
a view of the ad networks
assigned to the unit.
And I can click the
New Ad Network button
and choose a mediated network
to add to my own unit,
and you can see there's a bunch.
For this video, I've actually
created a fake ad network
with an SDK and everything.
It's called the Sample network.
It's just for this
recording, so you're not
going to see it here when
you set up your own ad units,
but you're going to want
real ads from a real network
anyway, because they
result in a real check.
And you can see I put
in an ad unit here.
Because AdMob uses the same
SDK that you would normally,
you do need to have an ad unit
for each mediated network.
Right, so now I've
got two ad sources
competing for my
impressions, which is great.
One thing I also want to
mention is how they get ordered.
So I can come in here and set
a hard estimate on the CPM
for what I think that
network is earning me,
and AdMob will use
that when deciding
which network gets first try.
AdMob also features something
called automatic network
optimization, which can
order the networks for you
based on how much
money they're making.
The server knows how
much you're getting
for AdMob ads, of course,
and for many other networks,
if you allow it access
to your account,
it can actually
pull reporting data
and then put it to
use in determining
which source should go first.
Just make sure you're
using optimization anywhere
you see it offered.
All right.
Once you've got an
ad unit configured,
the next step is to get
the project building
with the mediated
SDK and its adapter.
Let's take a look at
how that works with iOS.
First I'll import the
mediated SDK and its adapter
into my project.
Then I just need to
rebuild my app and profit.
OK, that's money
from a board game.
You're an odd person.
OK, here are my steps,
and I'm actually
going to do the
first two at once.
Here's my app, and
this is the project
that I need to get that
SDK and adapter into.
So I'll turn to the AdMob
mediation networks page.
There will be a link for
this at the end of the video
so you can find it easily.
It's a great resource for
anybody using mediation.
It lists all our
mediation partners
plus links to their SDKs,
adapters, and instructions,
so you can find out the
exact steps for each network.
Some networks, for
example, may have
CocoaPods that you can
just add to your pod file
and import that way, just
like you see me doing here.
But my simple network
just uses a static lib,
so I'm going to grab the files
and drop them into a group.
Again, every network has their
own particular instructions,
so make sure you check them
to see if they require linker
flags like the Objective-C
flag for categories
or any other additional steps.
All right, so that's it,
that's all for the importing.
Time to rebuild my app.
And there's my mediated ad.
Thank you, Gary, but that's
actually kind of the point.
You'll notice I
didn't have to change
any of my actual mobile code.
Referencing the GADBannerView,
loading the request,
none of that changed,
and yet AdMob
was able to fetch the
configuration from the server,
then call into
the adapter, which
called into the sample SDK,
and then came back with an ad.
Pretty cool, and the
only step left is profit.
All right, so that's iOS.
Now let's try Android.
As you can see,
it's the same steps.
Import, rebuild, profit.
Gary, those are skeeball tokens.
OK, so here are the
four steps again,
and we're going to start with
importing the mediated SDK.
Here's my project that I'll
be importing that SDK into,
and the first question is,
where do I get the SDK?
A great resource, again, is
our mediation networks page.
There will be a link at
the end of the video.
This page lists all of
our mediation partners
and has links to their SDKs,
adapters, and instructions.
The instructions
part is important
because different networks
distribute their SDKs
and adapters in different ways.
Some might host them on
JCenter, for example,
and I could come right
into my build.gradle file
and just add a dependency
for them and their adapters.
Some networks also bundle
the adapter into the SDK.
So there'd only be one
artifact to import here.
The most common
setup, though, is just
JAR files, which is how
my sample network does it.
So I'm going to
cut these back out.
So I'll drag and drop
the JAR into my project
here and get it done that way.
There's the SDK.
All right, so that was
the JAR for the SDK.
Now I just need the adapter,
which goes in the same way.
There we go.
All right, so now I've got the
mediated SDK and its adapter
imported into the project.
Time to rebuild my app.
And there's my mediated ad.
The AdMob SDK gets the
configuration from the server,
goes through the adapter
to the mediated SDK,
and comes back with an ad.
The only thing left is profit.
So that's AdMob mediation.
It's a little more work, but
it's also more competition
for your impressions, meaning
more potential profit.
Again, we use banners here
just to keep things simple,
but you can do other formats
like interstitials and rewarded
video as well.
To help you along
the way, here's
a link to our mediation
networks page,
which has a list of
all our mediation
partners plus links to
their SDKs, adapters,
and instructions.
We've also got implementation
guides for iOS and Android.
So check those
out, and as always,
you're welcome to bring
your technical questions
to our support forum.
And if you've got a question
about this video or an idea
for something we should
cover, leave a comment below,
and Gary and I will
see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]